مرحبا سهام يسعد صباحك بالخير ومرحب
بنادين انا في ورشه معتصم جبريل طالب
سوداني يدرس الهندسه الالكترونيه بمعدات
بدائيه بسيطه ابتداء من الورقه والقلم
بدلا من الحاسبه الالي الذي لا يمتلكه
معتصم استطاع اختراع عدد من الروبوتات
التي تقف امامنا الان حنتعرف على قصته
وحينضم لنا الان معتصم مرحب بك يا معتصم
طبعا ده ايروس اول روبوت لاك في العام
2019 مرحب بيك معتصم اتفضل
اول حاجه عرفنا كيف بتبدا يعني
طيب الروبوتات في البدايه ما هي جديد
علينا طيب الروبوتات حاليا هي مصنوعه من
مواد متوفره في حياتنا اليوميه عشان نقدر
نوصل بها مفهوم التكنولوجيا في المستقبل
زي ما شايفين بدون اي امكانات صنعاء
المستحيل
عارفه انه امكانيات ومعدات بسيطه جدا يعني
سهام ونادين مقبض
مقابض يعني عاديه عرفنا اكثر طيب المقاس
بنستخدمه لقطع الصاج المعدن الثقيل طيب
لصنع شنو البود الخارجي وعندك البوت
الداخلي بنستخدم شنو الزرديه بتاع شنو
البال بمستوى يعني لانه شنو دي التغنيه
بدائيه كده في نظريه انت
بتطبق عشان ما تصمم او تصنع روبوت النظير
اسمها في الاتحاد قوه طيب طبق المعدن مع
بعضه البعض يدينا ناتج متماسك كده يلا ما
في لحام لانه امكانيه عشان كذا جيت
بالبديل بتاعي اتحاد قوه بيدينا ناتج شنو
متماسك من المعدن
خلينا نتعرف عليهم اكثر الرباط ده وكمان
ايروس وروبوتات بندوره من وين بتجيب
الاسماء ولا الاسامي دي من الوحي تقريبا
انت بتدرس الهندسه الالكترونيه ممكن تكون
في عدد من الاختراعات الاخرى يعني طيب
الروبوتات هي شنو في العصر الحديث اكثر
حاجه يعني مهمه في العصر الحديث يعني اهم
شيء
الاختراعات عموما يعني الانسان مقبل على
عصر ما فوق الحديث عن الروبوتات بتلعب دور
كبير في الصناعه حاليا في الصين واليابان
والدول المتقدمه
ومعدل انجازه افضل وتستعمل في المناطق
الخطره بديل للانسان
[موسيقى]
طيب هو حاليا هيوسع الاسلاك ببعضها البعض
طبعا الروبوتات دي حديثه الصنع صحيح
زمن كافي عشان ما تتمكن من تطويره يعني
اخراجه بالشكل المطلوب فخلينا نبدا شويه
طيب هنا بنجرب شنو حركه الراس
بالامكانيه شنو المحدوده كده بيدينا شنو
حركه بسيطه
زي ما شايفين قدامكم وهنا طيب حركه
الزراعه
تمام
ممكن
طيب
مرحبا
تم اختراعي من قبل المخترع معتصم جبريل
شكرا في مرحله البدايه وان شاء الله غريبا
سيتم التطوير في حلول فتره القادمه
ان شاء الله
شكرا عوده لكما سهام ونادين يعني انا
بعتقد انه معتصم في حد ذاته رساله يعني
يجابه الظروف والتحديات ورغم ورغم ذلك
يستطيع ان يحلم ويفعل ويطور شكرا لكما